good morning Hank it's Tuesday I really
liked your video about North Korea and
it reminded me of a book I read called
escape from camp 14 that I want to talk
about but I'm having some trouble
finding it so I don't know if I'm going
to be able to let's just look you know
my exceptionally well cataloged home
library just isn't as well cataloged as
it used to be yes I found it Hank right
where it belongs under the German
editions of leaded snow right so this is
the story of shin dong-hyuk the only
person ever known to have escaped camp
14 camp 14 is at least we think the
worst camp for North Korean political
prisoners like the life expectancy for
males there is somewhere around 40 if
you don't get executed and the stories
that have emerged from camp 14 are truly
horrifying like for instance a
six-year-old girl who was beaten to
death for stealing five kernels of corn
but what you expect in these stories is
that our hero will suffer and he does
when Shin is 14 he is imprisoned in
solitary confinement where he can't
stand up for eight months and tortured
everyday also because he was born in the
camp the child of a marriage arranged by
guards he has never in his life eaten a
legal meal other than gruel made of
cabbage and corn and because
malnutrition is universal in camp 14 and
death by starvation is very common
access to food is a very important
incentive by the way people make jokes
about North Korea but it is not funny
this is not going to be a funny video I
think the other thing that you expect in
a story like this is that the hero will
have an indomitable will in some kind of
moral center that carries him through
all of his trials and tribulations which
is why it's so confounding when in the
first chapter you learned that this guy
Shin when he was 14 turned his mother
into the authorities when he overheard
her talking about escaping and then
eventually both shins mom and his
brother were executed Shin witnessed
this execution and at the time he felt
it was appropriate
Shin was born into a world where if you
hear people talking about escaping you
should tell on them and then they should
be executed that was moral also he knew
from having witnessed it that if he
didn't tell on his family and they did
escape he would be executed which makes
his own escape even more ethically
complicated because he knows he put what
remains of his family at risk and at
least a year Shin tell that his escape
wasn't motivated by his indomitable
human will seeking freedom he just
wanted food he became friends with one
of the few people who lived outside of
the camp and that guy was like you
should see the food they have in China
it's endless so Shin decided to escape
because he wanted the endless food they
had in China and I'll tell you why I
never believed this whole the human
spirit can't be broken thing you may
remember that in March of 2007 I was
hospitalized with an infect
behind my eye this infection was not
life-threatening Hank it wasn't even
really a threatening but it was pretty
miserable and uncomfortable and I
remember staring up at the acoustic
ceiling tiles of the hospital at like
2:30 in the morning one time in thinking
I'm ready for death like the problem
with extracting information by a torture
other than being wrong is not that
people won't talk it's that they will
talk so much they will say anything to
make the pain stop so the information
you get isn't reliable what makes this
story amazing is not the strength of the
human will but the fragility of it and
what makes you a hero is not that he's
born with some ethical Center it's that
he develops it in China and South Korea
and the United States after his escape
he is as he says evolving into a human
being
most of us undergo that evolution so
early that it feels innate but North
Korea reminds us it's not Hank I'll see
you on Friday